now once you stopped him in the first
fight the second fight
is the fight that's probably the most
famous fight because he bit a chunk of
your ear off and i saw it when you're
coming in here
show everybody that well do you ever
think about getting that fixed
well no it you know i know that's my
identification i ain't got my id
i can show my ear that is right if you
want to get into somewhere
um do you know who i am look at my hair
yeah yeah that's crazy man that was one
of the craziest moments when mills lane
looked at you and you were jumping up in
the air and looked at tyson and realized
holy [ __ ]
he bit a chunk out of your [ __ ] ear
right like what
what were you thinking at that time
biting him back
i'm serious i was getting ready to bite
the daylights out of him
and i'm gonna bite him in the face i'll
bite him his face i wouldn't
wait for the ear i'm gonna get the fat
chuck you know because
you know when you're from the ghetto
they say if you do something you got to
do it worse than what they did
right and so you know and i told mike in
a talk show i said no
i said no i i pretended like like i was
hurting real bad ass but
i'm going to trip you up and bite you
right in your face
everybody know what i was gonna do i
said but
uh you know this this prophet told us
before the fight
he told me he said look he's gonna do
something and your face area that but
you got to stay focused cause
if if you don't stay focused god that's
the only way he gonna get you
right so by him by email my ear when
and man and i knew i was getting ready
to bite him back
and and and but my corner person
started telling me keep my mind on the
lord and because the
the the prophet told me say only way
he can get you to get your mind he he
gonna do something to you
right i thought he gonna hit me with
elbow or
hip but anything like that but i never
ever
thought in my life he would bite my near
and by the chunky ear and it hurts so
bad and people something
how bad did it hurt i said did you see
how high i jumped
i said no it was crazy you just leaped
up in the air
yeah it hurt so bad and i said dan
i said dan that guy my corner guy
tim hallmark kept telling me keep my
mind on the lord
and i ain't want to hear that you know
even though he was saying that and i was
man i was still
i was just trying to remember that get
him i want to bite him i would
i i i really wanted to bite
him back and and all of a sudden i
it hit my mind that
they always catch the second person
right
i'm telling anything in life and i'm the
one that people always did something to
them they will always catch me
and i'm the only one to get get caught
all the time because they always catch
me trying to get to get back
so revenge is the lord so you don't go
get back because you're going to get
caught
yeah i was amazed that they didn't stop
the fight immediately
well they came back and checked and and
he asked me
you all right and i said yeah i at least
wanted to hit him
right i i really wanted to hit him
obviously i was i was really
upset well he tried to bite you twice
right well yeah he he bit me twice
he bit you two it bit me when when we
went back in and he thought i was going
to be scared and he said i caught him
with me two shots and
he bit me again man and i jumped back
and i'm
just getting ready to kick him in the
bowl
and and the bell rung and i went back to
the corner boy and i was so doggone man
i was i was really going to get him and
they stopped the fight yeah
and then i got mad because they stopped
the fight
because you were going to get him i i
wanted to get him back well it seemed
like he
thought that you were going to get him
and he was trying to find a way out well
yeah that's the only thing that made
sense well yeah
but the thing is only thing that i guess
with me and what i stand on is that i
was able to forgive him
and that's that has been the turnaround
in my life to
tend to make people people always wonder
about the ear
the earbud and i said but i forgave him
and everybody said
so what's special about that eyes but
everywhere i go around the world
with the muslim or whatever and people
say wow
this guy can forgive how can you forgive
when you're already beating the guy
yeah i said but you know but it's it's
what
is what life have to be if you're going
to survive with
even your brothers and sisters because
if you don't forgive nobody
you're going to be a mad person you're
going to find yourself locked up
right right and it's going to haunt you
whereas if you forgave him
it took a weight off your shoulders yeah
i'm i'm i
mike and i we do a lot of things
together because
the forgiveness part it's cool to see
you two together now i mean when when i
have seen things that you've done
together i'm like wow
it's crazy like after he bit you those
crazy fights
and to see you together laughing and
joking around together it's
it's pretty interesting well i mean when
you tell people you know when you don't
choose your parents
you don't choose your neighborhood you
didn't choose your skin color you didn't
choose to be tall or short
but you know this is your statue and and
two people two people who came from the
ghetto who box
and box was the only thing i did real
well
okay and football and but the thing is
that
after all that look how much money we
made
doing something that we by doing it
properly
we make money yeah we make money and we
can
both you know raise our family in the
way that
we want to raise them how long did it
take after the fight before you forgave
him
after after about about time i
i got into the locker room
and everybody started complaining man i
can't believe he did this and sisters
i said little i said did he bite you
they said no
okay i said he bit me right and i said
now i'm going to forgive him
you know what y'all got to forgive him
too wow they said what do you mean
forgiving
i said he ain't bite you i said he bit
me i said look i'mma forgive him
wow so you forgave him in the locker
room right after the fight
yes because the thing is the thing is i
you know i was really mad coming coming
down and people throwing water and
people man and they were upset because
they ain't getting a chance to see what
they really wanted to see right
like this and so they were mad and they
were upset and and
i asked you know me i figured
who in control of god so i said lord
what is this thing all about he said
forgiven
and i said who in the way i want to
forgive but this is what it is
we we're the two very important people
that everybody come to see
and they need to know that forgiveness
is a big part of life
and so i was able to do that so in the
point of being able to do that you know
i i
i realized that it made my life better
all over the world you got a clinic
kleenex yeah sure that's that's a very
powerful thing man it really is
that's a very powerful decision and you
know
it's a very powerful statement you know
to for you to forgive him after that
i mean that really that probably did a
lot of good for a lot of people to
realize man if evander holyfield can
forgive
mike tyson after he bit a chunk of his
ear off
i mean that's a that's a strong
statement of character right there
why you're not the thing is i didn't now
a little earlier than that then they may
not would have got that they would have
got something else
if you bit his face but but but
it's amazing how what time would do for
you right
right at one point in time i'm telling
you something something would have
happened
right but because they gave me a little
time to think about it and gave me
and and i was like and you know and you
know with me when
when things things don't go right i go
back to the prayers
lord what it's about all about right and
he said
forgiveness and you know and
i wouldn't be who i am is it runs from
forgiveness
everybody fell short somewhere right
like that so you know the whole big
thing is
and and i talked to the week a week
after that
i talked to mike we were we we was at
the all-star
basketball game in in new york and
and i looked up and and everybody was
streaming and i wonder what they were
streaming about
telling me to watch out i'm like watch
out for who
i looked up or mike and he had this big
bad coat and he
like this and so everybody was telling
me
that and it wanted me that mike mike
there
he had a big bear skin coat oh you know
he had a big fur coat that big fur coat
and the stuff like that he went through
number shake hands and wow and
a week after a week after you know i'm
just so you know your ear is probably
still sore
no no i won't even the thing is
with my ear my ears almost like a
testimony
right and you know it's almost like you
win a trophy yourself
that a person looking and said man he
forgave the guy so
i see that more people when they see me
they look at my ear
then after they see me here then they'll
smile like you
not in anger they smile and say well he
he forgave that guy
wow so when you saw mike did you guys
talk
yeah yeah a week after the fight yeah
what did he say to you
matter of fact his his room was next
door to mine and i didn't know
we came we came out we we come out at
the same time
he look he look he asked me is it all
good i said yeah
so we get on the elevator whoa
and we come down with the door open
everybody was shocked
so they were shocked wondering why we
wasn't fighting
right i didn't know i was just you two
in the elevator or other people
yeah yeah that's just you two in that
elevator yeah so
and so at the shocking part and they
said
man man we thought they would be
fighting and i told the guys
man i said you know how much money i got
paid in that fight how much money can
you say we gonna fight for free
was ever talk about a third fight wait
that yeah
i had people mention it you know they
they mention it
right and but you know the thing is is
that
they want to give a lot of money and
they they were asking me
to try to and my own thing is that
i i kind of feel like it's kind of bully
for you to ask somebody to fight
to fight you again when
you know you're gonna win again right
i'm you know so the whole big thing
is you know i just didn't i didn't think
that
if mike is mike wanted to do it i would
have done it
but i wasn't going to go ask i think i
think
you've been a bully when you know you're
better than somebody
and you want to you want to play them in
something that you know you're going to
beat them right right you know
it's a challenge just somebody to
challenge you think that i can come back
and beat you but you know just
just you know you feel that you better
and so i think it'd be wrong for me to
ask it
right no that's that's amazing i mean
but that just shows what kind of a
person you are
like that shows what kind of character
you have and that sort of
defines your career that you are the guy
that did
always seek the big challenges yeah